fundamentally at the core of everything
you want an interaction to be very
natural whether the design is superb and
it fits exactly the way that you would
anticipate it it just feels natural and
that's exactly where our field comes
into play how do you make that thing
natural it's not just a design
perspective but it's also what is the
content that you're showing how're you
going there it's transforming that
experience instead of just making it
better you're listening to the Microsoft
Research podcast a show that brings you
closer to the cutting edge of technology
research and the scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen heusinger big
data is a big deal and if you follow the
popular technical press you'll have
heard all the metaphors data is the new
oil the new bacon the new currency the
new electricity it's even been called
the new black while data may not
actually be any of these things we can
say this in today's networked world data
is increasingly valuable and it is
essential to research both basic and
applied today we welcome a special guest
to the podcast dr. igor paris ik is the
vice president of engineering and chief
data officer at linkedin the social
network for business and employment
today dr. Paris Nick talks about the key
attributes of a data scientist how a AI
and machine learning are helping
personalized member experiences why we
should all be big open-source fans and
how LinkedIn is partnering with other
researchers through their innovative
economic graft program to create
economic opportunity for every member of
the global workforce that and much more
on this episode of the Microsoft
Research podcast
egor Paris SiC it's great to have you
here on the podcast joining us via Skype
from Mountain View welcome thank you
very much yeah
Igor you're the the VP of engineering at
LinkedIn and you're also the chief data
officer
so in broad strokes give us an overview
of what you do and define your
responsibilities in each role so I'm an
engineer I build things I build the data
systems the the infrastructure that
powers the backend of LinkedIn and the
offline systems upon which we can
manipulate our data and I'm a scientist
in a sense that I build also the
algorithms and the personalizations that
we can provide to our members using
those systems to make the experience
better for members so the chief data
officer is briefing these two and has a
delegate of a component around policy in
the sense of making sure that on one
side the security engineering and legal
are talking together to address the
problems that can arise from their
LinkedIn has been both a thought leader
and early adopter in the field of data
science talk a little bit about that
field in general and more specifically
its history and current role at LinkedIn
well so history we can go far far back I
mean the terms data and science have
been defined that say in English
dictionary somewhere around the 17th
century but fundamentally I think it had
another change of direction somewhere
within the last 10 years it became
somewhere around 2007 or eighties which
we worked at LinkedIn and DJ party who
was my product counterpart at that time
somewhat coined the term within the same
more recent generation of it which was
more about an individual who would
really do five things who could hack
code and create a code who can reason
around the error and see the product
that it has inherent within it and hack
the product for it an inhibitor was
really good about machine running so I
can actually create those algorithms an
individual that could communicate so you
can see the story you can maybe write it
up but you can communicate that to
somebody else
not just towards somebody who's a very
all about it and great engineer who
would build infrastructure to because
you gotta remember that five or six
seven years ago the infrastructure
wasn't there so you have to build
everything today I see it migrating back
more towards the ability to create the
story the ability to see the pattern
through the data and then how it can
actually help a product and the term
data scientist is also a very
connotative term right now yeah i think
originally it was because we created
somebody that was different and we gave
it those two terms then later on as with
everything something becomes very hot
and sexy as a career so then everything
becomes data science right so you the
same thing as we call it the relevance
engineer is the same thing as we call it
data scientist though that we would call
it just researchers research engineers
data engineers know my way around the
same topic so certainly now you just
mentioned the term relevance which is
the term i've seen along and around your
website what is relevance mean it
certainly is something that's very
specific at LinkedIn where we move
towards being much more data inform in
the way that we build products and we
take decisions through time and then
bringing all these optimization
techniques we didn't want to call it
like optimizers optimize these optimizer
but making things more relevant and
that's where what we sort of lead around
the terminal relevance as the signs to
make things more relevant which is
fundamentally to make something more
personal to the individual I love that
and I think that resonates with a lot of
people so let's move over to the mission
of LinkedIn and it's to quote giving
economic opportunity to every member of
the global workforce so tell us what
role data science and research play in
making that mission happen well we do
have a fundamental role at the core
because when you create economic
opportunity for every member of the
global workforce you're creating that
economic opportunity for an individual
and that individual is always unique
certainly for malicious statistical
perspective it's part of a bigger bucket
but at the core that opportunity is
unique for that individual and in that
situation it means that you need to have
the build up
your products will build up your
experiences to that individual and the
tailoring to him or her and that's
exactly where I feel comes into play you
can create broad scope experiences but
when it starts getting into this
personalization aspect that's very
exactly where machine learning comes in
AI so in a recent post on your
engineering blog last year I was called
celebrating research excellence in
LinkedIn you gave a shout out to your
researchers for three things one of
course is making your products better
but you also referred to contributing to
the open source community and producing
world-class research peer-reviewed
research so why is the work of your
researchers important to the scientific
community at large and vice-versa I
would say I grew up with an ideal of
science and there was something that
resonated to me for a very very long
time and I don't know why you know you
grew up and there's some sentences that
stick with you and one that really stick
with me from very early on was standing
on the shoulder of the Giants and the
reason for that is that I could see the
broad scientific community as just one
community and however great you were you
were standing on somebody's shoulders
and sooner or later somebody would stand
on your shoulders it was never something
that it was done for yourself or
something that was done for the greater
community and leveraging all that
knowledge and moving it forward so then
of course within that scope contributing
back is very critical and very important
on two things one well we have the next
generation the next individuals and also
a measure of quality that you may think
that what you've done is great but may
be completely wrong so once you expose
it it's when you get that feedback that
you can actually learn being right or
wrong is not necessary fundamentally the
most valuable thing compared to just the
experience of learning so there's always
a bit of tension in the research
community between proponents of applied
research and basic research especially
in industry what's your philosophy about
the role of basic research in industry
where the ROI may be years out instead
of
mediate and what role does basic
research play at LinkedIn a company
whose product research is basically
embedded so I'm a big proponent of
research whether it's basic or applied
and it's all a matter of context I
believe that if you only limit yourself
to just applied research you tend to
sort of focus into just one area and
just dig in one one one more and you're
preventing yourself for life it's seeing
this paradigm shift that can occur basic
research has this goodness or this
overall perspective of that there's
something extremely challenging and it's
something that advances our
understanding and in itself is valuable
the application will follow or will not
follow but it would spark ideas within
the industry it's actually really hard
to do this basic research is just a
matter of whether you have the ability
to do so in the end the majority of
companies need to generate a certain
amount of revenue so you have to be able
to actually balance the two they're
Microsoft I think that was very very
good at balancing basic as well as a
abide research at LinkedIn when we
started that we were startup so you
can't really do basic research or
fundamental research and go to let's say
the CEO at that time and your group of
five or six I'd work on something and
don't worry about it in 200 years it
will make a difference two or three
years down the road so you have to to
play within it but still have a very
good perspective and overall view that
those two worlds are sort of intertwine
you can see the work that Microsoft has
done through the years
fundamentally you can say well at which
point of time does that say quantum
computing become basic to applied well
at the beginning it was certainly basic
and today it's almost apply although the
window is very far ahead it's it's not
happening tomorrow but it is happening
so let's talk about research cycle for a
second specifically at LinkedIn what
does it look like timewise and outcome
wise for you and how is it similar and
different from maybe some other things
because you have a really unique
approach to research at LinkedIn yeah
our cycles are much shorter like for
example the thing that we've published I
made it sure that very early on that
publications with
be about things that we've developed and
shipped on the site and had affected our
members experiences compared to things
that we've developed in an offline
environment on some sub queries and
whatnot and it moved symmetric it had to
have gone all the way in so in this case
our cycles are different in a sense that
the end value is around with it actually
went all the way down to the side now
tying in to what you said there's also
another cycle is how long do you
research before you make a difference
and there are window unlinked in is I
think most often except for
infrastructure it takes time to develop
it's probably maybe one or two years out
so it's certainly not my possible search
right so what's the relationship between
the researchers at say Microsoft
Research now and LinkedIn now that
you're sort of part of the same family
it's a multiple dimension one is in some
places we were let's say for example the
neural networks and using CNN's and GPUs
microstock was far ahead of the curve
and then we're benefiting from the
learnings from it for example how to set
up the topology of our clusters how do
we set up the topology of our let's say
records for it so then we've benefiting
from knowledge that somebody else has
done if you want and there's also
another side is well we have a different
perspective at times and then you're
just sharing it as I mentioned a couple
of times is that science advances or
research advances when you bridge those
different types of connections or
different types of fields so we bring
another perspective we've been
interacting very closely with the New
England team who has been our let's say
partner and pronto to the rest of
Microsoft Research as you can expect
there's a lot of interest from Microsoft
Research it's good that it's a bit
centralized so that we can actually
navigate around all those expectations
and demands
so you talk about the importance of what
you call conversations with your members
and there are multiple multi-level
conversations going on at any given time
so from a technical point of view how do
you stay on top of those and make sense
of those conversations in a meaningful
way I think it's a new perspective that
I've looked at it and you tend to think
that once you've found out this new
paradigm the way that you're gonna
communicate about it that it makes sense
and you wonder why you didn't see it
before
and probably in five to ten years I
would look at myself with a complete
idiot hours things trying to find a
model that that can help you reason
about a problem that you have in this
situation is about conversations in a
sense that I'm very early on we try to
do things with our members get our
members to do things and in this case a
conversation is really an informal chat
if you want between two individuals and
it's between it's a LinkedIn and the
member and early on what we've done is
say well we just blasted things we'll
just send you emails like there's no
tomorrow we did very good optimization
saying that well the morning and you get
the more likely you're going to do
something it's probably wrong no me and
my point somebody had done a study and
that seemed to be good of course when
you look at the high-level statistics it
seems to be fine but the conversation
was more like me screaming at you and
then when you start shifting by saying
well there's a lot of conversation we
can have so which one should have
communicate to you like right now and
today or in the recent past we've moved
more into thinking about well this
conversation doesn't stop just with the
action there is some sense of what are
you doing at Lincoln what you want to
achieve I think and those goals don't
stop tomorrow don't stop on the click
don't stop on the view don't stop on the
share they go for a longer period of
time
and the problem then starts shifting
because very often the techniques would
be I need to find it say a way to use
some different techniques to you
figure out what is your likelihood you
packed on something it's a probability
and in that case whether you do logistic
regressions whether you do different
types of all the way up to ponder on it
you come up with a number and that
number and then you optimize around it
and it's usually just about that
activity now if you viewed in the
context of a conversation that activity
doesn't stop right there and continues
we're having a dialogue it's going to go
on for a little one can't just optimize
for the next step so how do you go in
and out of them right and I thought that
it's the right time to think about it
although we had thought about it already
some years ago simply because of the
shift that we're seeing nowadays with
more and more of just a voice driven
interfaces appearing in a lot of places
which becomes another way to communicate
with an individual like in the beginning
was email then it was notification then
you have mobile pushes or pull downs
then you have windows tires on the
desktop and it becomes more and more
natural if it's avoids driven and if
it's voice driven then it is becoming a
real dialogue so once you have that
interface that you can leverage to build
up your application how are you thinking
about your optimizations if you're
thinking them still the logistic
regression work it's not gonna work what
does work well we're checking some early
steps a couple of years ago to look more
rounded quadratic constraints and
quadratic programming
they worked was that first items that
the across multiple different types of
dialogues that we have ingre members and
they work at let's say within the couple
of steps overall well that is ongoing is
there research which is this one or two
steps ahead right we're making good
progress and it's going to be actually
very very interesting to see how those
things are actually shifting yeah well
it's an exciting time I'm with so much
research and machine learning and people
trying things to see how it impacts both
the technology and the people that
they're working with
so you said at one point that machine
learning actually helps transform not
just in form but transform your inter
since with your members is that what
you're talking about here fundamentally
at the core of everything you want an
interaction to be very natural whether
the design is superb and it fits exactly
the way that you would anticipate it it
just feels natural and that's exactly
where our field comes into play how do
you make that thing natural it's not
just a design perspective but it's also
what is the content that you're drawing
how are you going there
so it's transforming that experience
instead of just making it better right
so I'm a LinkedIn member myself yeah and
I got to tell you I have noticed over
the last year a difference in how I'm
getting notified and one thing I've
noticed is that they seem more personal
to me like I would get a notification
about a person that I know or care about
as opposed to just feeling like you're
trying to pull me into the app right so
that's exactly what we were the last two
years to make it exactly that compared
to me pinging you a come back come back
come back I don't know why you will come
back but here it is is that you thousand
reasons for you to come back pick one
two more a here's something of value
within the context of your interest of
Lincoln or your value proposition we
believe are important here's something
that hey on one side you ought to know
it would be a good thing and on the
other hand it's to share with you the
network also right so I have to say that
makes me happy that the kinds of
technologies you're working on
especially machine learning technologies
that might be helping to broaden your
understanding of what I like what I'm
interested in is actually playing out in
the real world for people like me and I
tend to be skeptical and cynical of you
know high tech notifications I don't
like those red notifications on my phone
but when you pick up the rating we
associate red with Daniel but maybe it's
a maybe you need to do something like
right now but we have so many of them
and that's why I think we're ready for
that next iteration that other change I
look at my mailbox and it has like
numbers in the hundreds from time to
time I clear it out I look at my phone
and it's interesting to see how some
interfaces have decided to keep the
number low
other to keep the number high and to me
it seems that the ones that keep the
number high is though that are still
screaming at you and the one that keep
the number law is to say that I
understand that you have a busy life we
understand you have a lot of things and
a lot of applications on your phone
let's make sure that if I put a number
out there it's something that would be
really good for you too now compared to
just come on
and that's a fine line right because
you're competing for people's attention
in an increasingly crowded world and
where do you you know to stop all caps
and whisper it seems to be working right
yeah for me not that we can see it all
so of course everybody is to some extent
in form of the metrics of the product
performances and we see that changed
yeah originally people would be confused
about a while LinkedIn and now it
becomes more obvious and then it becomes
more natural because you actually steer
the conversation to the right places
right which is interesting this whole
topic of conversation that we're on
right now is talking about how
technology is actually making me feel
more personal towards a particular
product which is somewhat sort of
backwards but I like it it's working
good job didn't science the terms
themselves were not glued together to
define what we're doing less than seven
eight years ago it's here I granted
there are some others that you can that
I was sort of anticipating that was
going to go there but it's similar with
this sense of personalization or this
sense of it makes sense within the scope
of what I do queries and in the past we
used to call it an augmentation of
yourself oh yeah an agent that works
that extends and works for you and it
fits naturally within what you do and
similarly the data science back then
people will look at your plan is what
are you talking about what does it mean
and today you can start seeing it you
said I will let's bring all these AI dis
bring all these technology to make me
Chronicle better better as that
understanding what is happening around
me but in the way that I connect
interact with it auch meant the way that
I can deal with the problems that I need
to get right work and making better
attack
[Music]
most of the researchers that I've talked
to on this podcast are big open source
fans and I think you are too you've
published articles given talks and
you're on the open source counselor you
oversee the open source counsel at
LinkedIn why is open source a good thing
especially for researchers well I
started by saying that I love science
because we all stand on the shoulders of
giants
well open source is certainly a movement
that has just accelerated and I have to
say that at the beginning everybody was
wondering you're going to stick for Rio
is you want to stay forever but it just
fit so naturally the way that we develop
things as developers if you look at any
company if that has more than two people
eventually there's some level of
abstraction that I've built and people
just leverage the code of each other an
open source is just a further extension
to reaching out to the entire community
I was always a big proponent even prior
to starting at Lincoln because we were
just leveraging solutions and every
other individuals had developed for
example that LinkedIn the search engine
originally the correlate was a loosing
an Apache open source project then we
felt like well since we riding on those
lines we should contribute back and some
other individuals we create businesses
around it and that creates a whole
ecosystem that becomes that much much
better then through it we stumbled upon
truth some of them being that you
actually write much better code when you
actually think about open sourcing it
compared to you when it's kept
internally and not only do you write
better code but you have a better way to
reason about it you look at it does it
make sense does it not make sense as it
come down what it's out there or does it
not complement what it's out there
and a lot of goodness comes through that
so when we talked before you mentioned
open source code as similar to a
peer-reviewed research paper that you're
publishing in some way can you explain a
little bit about what you think about
that I usually take two allegories about
open source one it's it feels like peer
review because in a sense you're writing
a piece of software you're documenting
it and you're pushing it out there but
there's so many publications
and if your paper is not good nobody's
going to actually build other things
from it you're not going to be cited
much and open-source is the same it if
you're not investing into your project
to make it great nobody's gonna actually
really leverage from it and I used to
take another one which is I guess
through my life experience open sourcing
is a little baby also it grows but then
at some point of time you've got to let
it have its own life and it's like your
kid that grew up and that becomes mature
and they want to do something that you
may not have a vision which is perfect
and open sourcing is the same sometimes
have a tendency to keep that kid at home
and said well no let them discover it
the rest of the world Igor I just open
sourced my daughter at the University of
Washington let's talk about
LinkedIn's relationship with the larger
academic and research communities
through public-private research
partnerships you have a program called
the economic graph and it started I
think as a challenge but now it's an
ongoing program give us an overview of
what it is and how it came about and
what research you focus on so the
economic path challenge the idea of
letting external individuals from Newton
look at our data and answer some
extremely protein and the relevant
question was there from the time that I
joined again I'd probably even before
that so how do we create an environment
where we preserve that privacy of the
individual and open it up to the
community and that was what the economic
life challenge was we basically reached
out to the global community friends and
family and others to say well if he had
Lincoln's data what are the questions
that you would want to answer and within
that we had more than 200 proposal that
came back we selected 12 the idea were
just brilliant it ranged from how do you
think about micro industries in
different environments from a Geo
perspective like the fashion industry in
Milan or the say the rise of electric
cars in the valley for example to how do
women define himself or write about
themselves anything compared to
if you control some multiple factors but
again the resources are limited so you
reach out to the community to go so the
people that participate in this with you
their academics or researchers come from
all different walks of the research life
and they participate by presenting a
proposal and getting access to some of
the data from LinkedIn is that how that
works but originally we as I mentioned
we just broadcast again we got a lot of
proposals back and then we would
evaluate on the idea of the interesting
mass of the idea but also the ability to
execute on that idea meaning that you
have the ability to using out the answer
the question right most ended up by
being from academia what's your overall
goal with economic graph to create
economic opportunity for every member of
the global workforce and that's where I
got to believe a bit more into the
vision and the mission of LinkedIn to
create economic opportunity and not only
an economic opportunity but the right
one for you the one that just prior to
so the way that we use the economic
growth upon one sided it's certainly to
be descriptive because it provides a
value of the labour market provides an
image whether it's instantaneous or
whether it's in the past
it provides a sense of what are people
doing in the labour market and what are
the movements within it it's a living
entity and you provide a picture of it
and this tremendous value to it because
the timelines are very quick you don't
have to wait six months or three months
to get a government statistic but it
provides a good picture so then that is
extremely valuable
yeah the other is to understand and see
that careers are also leaning to migrate
the shift from one domain to another you
have multiple careers in your life fund
and understanding what it takes and what
it doesn't take and helping our members
so I should build up that so that's
where the economic graph is also moving
to figure it out how do I share that
information with you how do I keep you
nurture your career and in the end well
that's the critical opportunity thank
you along your life cycle everybody
I believe starts a job thinking that
it's going to be the job that you're
going to do forever
I started LinkedIn thinking that two to
three years of my life and ten years
later I'm still here but and then
actually I'm still here because of the
vision and the belief
the ability we can move it forward but
once you think in that role you seeing
the fluidity of the labour market as
being in something that that is
important and that wasn't an economist
before coming to Lincoln whatsoever but
there's some very fascinating mind frame
around it all frameworks to think about
it
[Music]
you're a researcher you've ended up
parlaying a research interest into a
career what advice would you give
researchers who were heading into the
field of maybe data science or even more
generally as they prepare for their next
steps after grad school the main one be
curious continue to be curious there's a
sense of if you went into getting a PhD
you wanted to solve a problem there's
something that was missing you went at
it and you dig in and and you attempted
to move the answer a bit further along
that's great it's certainly one of the
best experiences on the other hand make
sure that what that happened don't just
limit the focus I think that sometimes
what researchers are on missing that yes
it is valuable to dig in very much but
be aware of the rest and make
connections from that to maybe better
what you're doing or see different
paradigm different perspectives I was
listening to Fabiola Gianotti just
recently who's the head of the CERN she
studied first humanities before moving
into physics and I view myself as a
scientist also and the things that are
value more that I wish I had more
growing to school is actually humanities
not math all the rest because I feel
like no I'll get this anyway so that's a
given but the rest is missing and if you
think about it this way today at 19 I'm
trying to understand from a members
perspective what are the struggles that
they're going through in order to make
their career better when you get that
more by this side exposure but is
interest
make these connections and these
connections have to be outside of just
your domain so if I had one
encouragement is keep the wonder just go
for it just keep the wonder and be
willing to learn different topics in
challenges so follow Igor persik thank
you so much it's been a delight to talk
to you today you're welcome very much
thank you
to learn more about how researchers are
harnessing and using data to make the
digital world and your experience with
it better visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides